[Música]
margarita martín es profesora de la
espol preocupada por la falta de
espíritu crítico e investigativo de los
bachilleres propuso junto a otros
profesores crear un entorno motivador
que proteja las mentes curiosas de los
niños y jóvenes así nace ajam parte de
la ciencia en octubre del 2005 el primer
centro interactivo de ciencias del
ecuador y el único semillero de futuros
científicos e ingenieros
y la razón por la que estoy aquí hoy
queridos amigos es porque creo en el
poder transformador de la educación la
educación cambia las personas las
personas afectan su entorno los entornos
modifican la sociedad pero
lastimosamente las experiencias
enriquecedoras que crean oportunidades
no son comunes a todos
mis primeras reflexiones sobre éstas
a cuestiones sobre educación experiencia
oportunidades se remontan a cuando era
una jovencita de 15 años y por razones
familiares tuve que cuidar a durante mis
vacaciones a mi sobrino de año y medio
mi sobrino tenía muchos juguetes y entre
esos tenía unas letras magnéticas que él
ponía en la refrigeradora y como todos
los juguetes del aprendiz a su nombre se
me ocurrió que también aprenda el nombre
de las letras
sorprendentemente el aprendió muy rápido
todas las letras del abecedario entonces
se me ocurrió experimentar con la
combinación de las letras y entonces la
m con la mamá en mí sin embargo no
mostró mucho interés según mi criterio
no estaba aprendiendo y abandoné mi
primera experiencia como maestra de
lectura sin embargo pocos días después
cuando yo le estaba dando de comer sobre
la mesa había un libro grande de
matemáticas y él me dice tía más
como si más entonces me di cuenta que si
había estado aprendiendo pero que
necesitaba un poquito más de tiempo y
seguir jugando de tal manera que en
pocos meses el aprendió a leer antes de
los dos años y así más adelante unos
doce años después con mi propio hijo
debido a que mi sobrino finalmente tuvo
problemas disciplinares porque cuando a
los cuatro años él fue al preescolar y
le daban las hojitas de trabajo con
instrucciones para la maestra él decía
hoy día vamos a aprender la letra y
claro en la mala stratus que nombrarlo
ayudante de lectura
entonces con mi propio hijo como que el
experimento lo gradué un poco y él
aprendió a nadar muy temprano a patinar
muy temprano pero como yo le leía y mi
esposo tiene libros y yo tenía libros
entonces él quería aprender a leer de
hecho era un castigo para él yo no te
enseño las letras
entonces se portaba bien
y mi reflexión era bueno
los niños son unas esponjas y no todos
tienen esa excelente oportunidad no
todos tienen la experiencia de ser
estimulados y sin embargo hablamos de
ponerlos a competir y entonces la
competencia
no funciona
abajo
ya
a dónde apunta
aquí
arriba ok entonces como se inician las
diferencias a nadie se le ocurriría
justo poner a competir en términos de
fuerza a un niño desnutrido con un niño
bien alimentado sin embargo
sin embargo si estamos hablando de
competir a nivel internacional en
términos de tecnología con niños que son
abandonados que no son estimulados y
niños que si reciben el estímulo la foto
de acá son de niños ya en el parque ajá
que vamos a hablar más tarde
entonces las las diferencias se
mantienen cuando hablamos no solo de
nutrición para sus cuerpos sino también
para sus mentes
algunos politécnicos aquí reconocerán
esos profesores fueron mis profesores
sin un tiempo fueron mis colegas y
hablábamos de aunque nosotros recibíamos
a los mejores recibimos los mejores
bachilleres en matemáticas y en física
de la ciudad porque para ir a la
politécnica tengo que hacer perdón ya me
estaba saliendo tengo que hacer casi un
genio así no y de todas maneras ellos
cuando estaban en la clase no
despertaban su espíritu crítico no eran
a veces consumidores pasivos repetidores
de la información y entonces con ellos
comenzamos a perfilar y a pensar cuáles
deberían ser las características de los
bachilleres que nosotros queremos
recibir y también las características de
los profesionales que queremos de
ofrecer y se nos ocurrió o mejor yo
salió la construcción de este estribillo
es un estribillo que queríamos repetirlo
a lo largo de toda la carrera
y pensadores de tiempo completo
con imaginación curiosos solidarios
sensibles a las necesidades de su
entorno humildes y eso es lo importante
la humildad es el reconocimiento de
nuestras limitaciones y a veces eso es
muy difícil de encontrar pero además
atrevidos es decir que no sean temerosos
que con tenacidad ese es otro valor
importante la persistencia que no se
rindan emprendan proyectos para vivir
mejor ellos pero también para beneficiar
a la sociedad ok
en el año 2000 mediante un proyecto
entre bélgica y la espol el componente
blind pensaba en la creación de un
centro interactivo de ciencia para mí
eso fue excepcional porque había tenido
la oportunidad de visitar entornos como
bibliotecas y centros interactivos en
otros países en donde veía como los
niños tenían la oportunidad de tener
experiencias enriquecedoras
estimuladores y entonces yo como dice mi
esposo metida me enganché en ese
proyecto y la espol ofreció dar una zona
allí que está ahorita frente al cti para
un parque interactivo de ciencias el
gobierno del infa comenzó a trabajar y
soñamos con el primer centro interactivo
de ciencias que sería eso no queremos
pero obviamente eso eran millones de
dólares que no lo podía poner la espol y
que esperábamos que el gobierno central
o el gobierno seccional los pusiera
lastimosamente eso se quedó en sueños
pero ya estábamos enganchados
y cautiva mos algunos estudiantes y
algunos profesores y comenzamos a pensar
en desarrollar exhibiciones no muy caras
pero que pudieran ser estimulantes para
los estudiantes de los colegios de las
escuelas que los visitaremos que
lleváramos y queríamos despertar la
capacidad de asombro de desarrollar la
curiosidad
y la creatividad queríamos que no sea un
asunto de transmitir conocimiento en el
niño o el joven debía engancharse en su
propio ciclo de cuestionamiento entonces
esas fueron algunas exhibiciones y
comenzamos con las visitas de los
estudiantes de los colegios y también
comenzamos a llevar estas exhibiciones a
bueno lo primero que fue fue a loja
después nos fuimos a jipijapa después
nos fuimos bastante elena a montecristi
nosotros mismos como profesores decíamos
que la meta había cambiado
no queríamos transmitir conocimientos
sino que los estudiantes los crearan y
el rol de profesor se movía de ser un
transmisor a un facilitador del proceso
construimos exhibiciones eso era en loja
queríamos que los estudiantes gozarán
del gol intelectual
usted ha visto cuando los niños aquí el
fútbol es muy común no pero cuando meten
gol ese es el héroe y quieren volver a
sentir esa euforia no a sí mismo cuando
el niño descubre algo cuando lo entiende
cuando lo domina entonces se aficiona
por eso y eso es lo que queríamos
producir ofrecer experiencias divertidas
estimulantes alimentar y orientar la
curiosidad ese es una exhibición del
arco romano todos esos son proyectos de
los estudiantes allí vemos en loja está
deseando morph ismos que es una mezcla
de matemáticas con arte
y nació el nombre de ajá fue realmente
un concurso en donde algunos creativos
buscaban el nombre y ajá nos pareció lo
hermoso parque de la ciencia la parte
verde ese fue el logo y la idea detrás
de la intersección ajá es el momento
mágico en que ante un estímulo una
experiencia uno conecta y dice
no entendí y eso es lo que queremos
queremos los momentos ajá para nuestros
niños nuestros visitantes ese es un
giroscopio atrás está levanta tu peso
son exhibiciones al aire libre cuando
logramos tener ya dejamos de ser nómadas
y logramos tener nuestra primera versión
de nuestra carpa fue en octubre del 2006
y comenzamos a recibir visitantes de
colegios también dimos talleres esos son
talleres para profesores de matemáticas
la idea es de que ellos pudieran
utilizar esto de lo concreto a lo
abstracto ahí son algunas de las
exhibiciones del parque
ok ahora
no pudimos tener nuestro gran edificio
pero conocimos una pareja peruana muy
interesante en un doctor en física y
ella una doctora en matemática que en su
propia casa
recibía a los niños en las vacaciones y
les hacía hacer experiencias entonces
nosotros dijimos en la espol podríamos
tener un poquito más de facilidades que
en una casa nosotros tenemos las aulas
tenemos los laboratorios tenemos los
profesores tenemos nuestra carpa y
entonces nació la idea de los semilleros
de futuros científicos e ingenieros
lastimosamente como la idea que esos
cursos eran muy experimentales
necesitábamos materiales necesitábamos
poder financiar a los profesores
entonces salió como un curso vacacional
financiado siempre de todas maneras
teníamos becas para por lo menos dos o
tres niños ahora en qué consiste y cuál
fue la idea
y los semilleros de futuros científicos
ingenieros el que los niños tuvieron un
trabajo participativo que los
experimentos fueron sencillos con
materiales comunes actividades con baja
barrera de entrada todos deberían de
poder tener éxito en el primer intento
pero con alto techo y de ser posible que
envuelva la mayor cantidad de los
sentidos para que todas las zonas del
cerebro sean estimuladas es un curso que
ya ha tenido nueve versiones durante
nueve años consecutivos todos los
inviernos tenemos niños niños son cinco
semanas todos los días de la semana de
lunes a viernes de 9 a 12
un día juegan juegan con matemáticas con
física con química con biología y con
ingeniería y ese ha sido nuestro
producto más exitoso
y aquí hay algunos de los mensajes que
nosotros decidimos a los niños no tengas
miedo a equivocarte no te preocupes por
el tiempo no te preocupes por las
preguntas no te preocupes por la
respuesta preocúpate por el proceso
y esas son algunas de las fotos
los semilleros
no tengo problemas con que pase
pues usando algunos principios para los
profesores tenemos que infundir
confianza en la autoestima la seguridad
de que sí lo puedo es importante para
los niños
yo creo que me ayudan pasándolo ok allí
otra de las cosas de las normas
importantes en el pse millones que nunca
le decimos a los chicos cuál es la
solución ellos mismos tienen que
descubrirla ese es una de las cosas más
difíciles de hacer en la educación
tradicional y ustedes pueden ver algunos
de las experiencias pero
[Música]
si ella
ok ese es un ejemplo en física esto es
un ejemplo de matemáticas
y como yo soy profesora de matemáticas
nos vamos a quedar aquí y vamos a darle
un breve vistazo de lo que son las
actividades en el semillero ok
imaginémonos que decimos a los niños que
han tenido un accidente de aviación y
que hay un resto del fuselaje en el
oriente y del del avión y que ellos
tienen que decidir cómo construir un
reservorio de agua entonces imaginémonos
que esto es el fuselaje del avión ellos
pueden decidir construir un cilindro de
esta manera o pueden decidir
de esta otra manera
claro esto aunque está aquí pensemos no
mire esta es la hoja
pero esto
la dividimos para 2
y después
exactamente congruentes dos rectángulos
congruentes y después a partir de cada
uno de estos formamos dos cilindros el
un cilindro este que está aquí y el otro
cilindro este que está acá
la pregunta es cuál de los dos tiene
mayor capacidad de almacenamiento
piensen ustedes hay tres opciones no me
diga pero piense
el que tiene mayor capacidad de
almacenamiento es
o los dos tienen igual
bueno yo le he hecho esta experiencia en
muchos especialmente a los niños y la
mayoría de los niños dice igual hay
otros que dicen que es el más alto y
unos muy pocos que es este bueno como
vamos a comprobarlo vamos a pedir aquí a
mi ayudante y vamos a hacer lo siguiente
por favor
vierta aquí arroz porque si no sería
cuidado despacito
bueno esto es lo que más le gusta a los
niños regar el arroz
ya ok
despacito
entonces la idea es de que se llene
hasta el tope el cilindro
entonces la mayoría de los niños hace la
construcción todo lo hacen desde el
principio doblan la hoja la parten la
pegan ya está ahí ok entonces está full
el cilindro alto y ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es que este cilindro más ancho lo
ponemos allí y
puede levantar eso excelente
y qué pasó note que aquí todavía cabe
bastante
entonces es el cilindro más ancho el que
tiene mayor capacidad ahora les voy a
hacer otra pregunta
así ahora comparó este cilindro y
construyó uno que es el doble de alto
significa que ahora doblo mi hoja a4 así
o la otra opción es que como
y la pego a lo ancho para que sea el
doble de ancho
tengo mi cilindro doble de alto doble de
ancho cual tiene mayor capacidad
claro ahorita ya ustedes aprendieron
vieron aprendieron que es el ancho pero
cuanto más
será el doble
bueno si efectivamente es el doble y eso
es bien importante porque hasta
ingenieros hasta ingenieros cometen el
error de decir a ver tengo un ducto de
desfogue y es de 30 pulgadas de diámetro
ay pero es muy caro entonces mejor le
pongo dos de 15
grave error es la mitad ok ya me tengo
que ir lo único que quiero compartir con
ustedes es la convicción de que debemos
darle oportunidades si estoy abierta y
espero hombros y manos para seguir
llegando a más personas gracias
[Aplausos]